اعلنت الحكومه المصريه ابرام عقود لبيع
اصول حكوميه لشركات خاصه بقيمه تصل الى
مليار وتسعمائه مليون دولار كان ذلك خبر
حلقتنا نناقشه في ثلاثه مسارات ما هي
الاعتبارات والحسابات الاقتصاديه التي
دفعت الحكومه المصريه لابرام عقود لبيع
اصول حكوميه كيف ارى الشركاء الخليجيون
للحكومه المصريه خطواتها الجديده وما هي
الانعكاسات المحتمره لسياسه الحكوميه
الجديده على الاقتصاد المصري
ان مصر لديها التزامات لوتعهدات لدى صندوق
النقد الدولي ويجب عليها ان تفي على الاقل
بجزء منه حتى تتاكد انها تسير في طريق
الاصلاح التي تعهدت به المفاوضات مع
الاشقاء في الخليج واضح انها توقفت مساله
سعر الصرف كانت مساله جوهريه الاقتراب من
سعر الصرف في ظل الظروف الحاليه سوف يؤدي
الى كوارث للمواطن المصري وحتى للدوله
المصريه
باكثر من اثنين مليار دولار وهذا لم يتم
الامر يكمن في ان المستثمرين المصريين حتى
داخليا يعني نحن دوله للاسف منذ قيام
الجمهوريه الجديده في 3 يوليو 2013 نستورد
اكثر من 70% من احتياجاتنا سواء غذائيه او
السلع الوسيطه التي تدخل من ضمن الصادرات
كان هناك حاله من المضاربه على الجنيه
والدولار فبالتاكيد الدولارات التي تم
جمعها من السوق المصريه
ذهبت الى خزائن بعض رجال الاعمال المصريين
ومن هنا كان الاتفاق الوسط
[موسيقى]
مثل هذه المشاكل
الحقيقه الاقتصاديه الطارئه
والاستثنائيه فلقد جو غير صحيا للاستثمار
في دول او مساعده دول بحجم مصر فجاءت
المطالبات باصلاحات في الاقتصاد اعتقد ان
بيع الاصول ايضا ياتي من ضمن الخصم اصابع
اهم الاصلاحات عمليه الخصخصه محاوله فصفصه
قطاعات في مصر ويقول القطاع الخاص كاداره
لانه هو الاكفئ وهو المعتمد الان عالميا
في دول العالم المتقدم ايضا هناك الافصاح
والشفافيه يحصل العمليه ليست عمليه كامله
عمليه
اقتصاديه كامله ايضا قد تكون دول خليجيه
ايضا صاحبه الدول الخليجيه قد تكون تحولت
الى ايضا
الاستفاده او محاوله الاستفاده من فرص
الاستثماريه في مصر المستثمر الخليجي
موجود في مصر اعمار وموجوده بقوه في مصر
كثير من الشركات موجوده في السابق في مصر
وهناك فرص الجميع ينتظر استقرار على الاقل
استقرار اسعار الصرف ثم بعد ذلك يبدا
بالعوده للاستثمار في مصر بما ان مصر دوله
لا نستطيع الاستطلاع عنها للاسف يعني الان
البيع يتم لانقاذ ما يمكن انقاذه نحن
نحاول يعني اظهار
التزمنا امام صندوق النقل الدولي والمؤس
الدوليه وكذا الشركاء الخليجيين بان مصر
في طريقها الى بعض اصلاحات هيكليه عن طريق
بيع الاصوله احدى الطلبات الطلب الاكبر
الذي طلبه صندوق هو تقارب المؤسسه
العسكريه من الاقتصاد
[موسيقى]
المواطن المصري يقل لان ليس هناك مصادر
للعمله الاجنبيه يعني لا يوجد زياده
حقيقيه في الصادرات الغير بتروليه وكذا
غياب الشفافيه والوضوح سينعكس
التضخم ازدياد في معدلات الفقر ويعني
الامر لن يتحسن الا بوجود خطط تنميه
حقيقيه اذا قفزت اسعار البنك المركزي
الرسميه على الاسعار الموجوده في سوق
الموازيه السوق الموازيه سوف تموت لكن
المشكله ان المواطن المصري بالرابع
المستحيلات ان يتحمل وصول هذه الاسعار انت
تتحدث عن مواطن يعني لم يعد يستطيع ان
يوفر الاحتياجات الاساسيه لحياته اليوميه
يعني انا في اعتقادي ان اداره سعر الصرف
في مازق من ربع المستحيلات يعني لا احد
يستطيع ان يتوقع ما سوف تنخفض العمله
تقريبا سته اضعاف او سبعه اضعاف يرتفع
معادلات الفقر فهذا امر ينذر بموقف مبابي
نتمنى ان تعود الحكومه المصريه الى
اجراءات اصلاحيه حقيقيه